where was distillation from the event
it's not letting me go okay
okay
so we all agree that image sets have
been really um important for development
deep learning especially um
imagenet and c4 and amnest you see a lot
of that in academic talks
there are actually lots of other very
interesting images in science from
cellular biology
cosmology and also the videos like the
protein folding
so the work i present here is very much
i'll call scientific machine learning or
machine learning for science
you really try to bring in science into
machine learning algorithms at the same
time we want to use machine learning to
push forward science development and we
interact between the two
and um
we have high standards for um list of
algorithms it's not just for
some data sets you really want to make
sure it's part of the knowledge of
science
and i think the theory of
scientific machine learning should
really couple itself with
insights for practice
and we should also have very good
software
for other people to use
so my group's approach to scientific
machine learning are called integrated
we really have students sitting in the
web lab
and become as a
scientist as possible as much you can
learn on your own from collaborators
and then we develop machine learning
algorithms to solve a particular problem
before we generalize to another problem
so we see that in the examples i will
cover today and then we kind of when we
see the empirical evidence we take a
step back and we do try to understand
from a strategic point of view
interpretation is very important for
scientific machine learning right you
know that we have this eu
data protection regulation give everyday
right
to explanation but in scientific machine
learning expressing very important most
of the science books you open are not
made of equations that are made of
narratives so you really have to turn
without the insight from the algorithm
the theory into
narrative
and we have this paper
with my current and former students
to define interpretation learning
because there were a lot of papers and
so what we mean by interpretation
so we developed this
three component
framework called pdr
and
the important thing we try to bring out
is relevance
the interpretation you need to have a
defined audience
and also a problem
so even if it's the same audience
depends on different problems you want
might want to come up with different
interpretation you want to use
predictive accuracy
to really check reality and you also
have descriptive accuracy to communicate
and
you can use
global predictive accuracy
we can look at a lot of investigate
different cases different data points or
different images see how the predictions
are not just average
and
descriptive accuracy has a lot to do
with the audience
and can you really capture the
relationship learned by the machine
learning models
and the relevancy i think is at the
heart
and people usually think this way that
you have decision trees it's most
interpretable those this regression
it's kind of a little more less
interpretable but still pretty good and
then you end up with deep learning which
become pretty much black bugs so what
you will see later we're going to turn
this deep learning scientific problems
into something like wavelets which is
very integral in physical sciences
and
the relevancy in scientific machine
learning
really means that you the inside have to
correspond to the facts and maybe you
can do experiments afterwards to really
uh check some of the facts you learned
or the interpretation learned from
machine learning model
so this is just like a pr
overview so for the rest of the talk
i'm going to share some results we're
very excited about
just got into nurse
oh it's going to happen i think
this week or next week
adaptive wave distillation from
like rest that like 18 layers to
something like 30 uh coefficients
and we started with a cosmology problem
and then we just use the same
methodology as a generalization for
cellular biology problem i also give
very good results
that's kind of supervised learning and
then i will turn to
unsupervised learning because wavelets
can also be learned with unlabeled data
from natural images
and we have been working with these drug
software biologists and also
neuroscience from at an institute just
use unsupervised learning
and you don't get wavelets depends on
what's input the dictionary learning
will actually give you other biological
meaningful
partitions
that are not various at all so this
really brings in the importance of the
input distribution to the inspection
learning algorithms
and now and with
some local and global identifiability
and theoretical results on dictionary
learning
so the first
kind of motivating
project with
cosmologists from um
at the time um france why i was in
berkeley now back in france and my
postdoc current post and current student
woo suk and chandan
and then france was um collaborators
so here they have been using
deep learning to try to understand some
fundamental parameters of cosmology
unsimulated data
so they have this fundamental parameter
something called omea-m it's about the
beginning
mass of the universe and they do forward
simulation and the purple image on the
right is from the simulation that's
supposed to be the map of mass in the
universe
and can you recover
because you know omega m
using um
machine learning measures
it turns out that
convolutional network works really well
the thing is how
what does it really learn
what do we really
understand how does deep learning do
this inversion right this is slip over
simulation and you kind of end up with
this parameter
and i've always talked to them they said
frequency domain is very important so we
want the interpretation in the frequency
domain
so
you can turn whatever the interpretation
you have
through this
true year and inverse free of transform
and make f prime
and then just now again understanding in
the f prime prime so a lot of problems a
lot of um interpretation method can be
done through this transformation
and we have a particular one we have
been using for language
natural language problems and also for
image problems so this was developed not
for scientific purposes this was just a
generic machine learning interpretation
to go beyond
just a single feature to get importance
for
combinations of features
so for this
we could
now
really
give importance not just for a word but
also combination words
you can have
what's the importance of very good not
just not very and good
and you decompose them it's kind of
alkylation alkylation
approach
and you collect the different terms like
they run through the
deep learning network and then you end
up with its importance for single words
and also combination words you can do
the same thing for um
images similarly you can get importance
so why you use this generalize this to
the frequency domain
and now we can give an important score
for each frequency domain 0.1.2.3
and you end up seeing that there's a
peak at 0.3 really saying that the
frequency 0.3 is very important for this
prediction
and
what you have is saying that if you want
to do simulation you want to pay
attention to frequency 0.3 but other
high frequencies are not so important if
you want to use deep learning to get
omega m
and this is yes yes
i met all right that you want to predict
yeah you want to um you want to estimate
but it's not known right so how can this
yeah or maybe no this is a simulation
so you know that that's why you can
develop a supervised learning message
so they have certain setup have certain
um
they also change other parameters
so that's why it's known
to use this simulation to see whether
your method works and hopefully you as
use that to estimate the real data
yeah in general it's not known right
but in simulation images
so it's kind of like um
a sandbox
for or doing the real estimation
so this is just very uh toy example to
show that
if you use other measure like integrated
gradient or sharp and deep lift
for this very simple problem the our um
contextual decomposition cd can really
figure out the frequency
uh much better well they do pretty well
but you have quite a big lift but it's
very simple um
function
so that's where we were before we jumped
into wavelets
so when you do
through your kind of analysis the next
thing you want to do is probably local
free analysis which is uh
wavelets
and people already actually using
wavelets to do estimation for omega m
and this is
the nurse paper again led by wusu and
chandan and our
collaborator francois nanusi and
biologist wuko from
berkey advanced imaging center who is
the cell biologist we
i'll show you the second example
so here is the idea that we have this
rest that works pretty well
and can we actually make it a simpler
model and something meaningful out of it
and there's already this line of work
called model distillation so you start
with a complex like deep learning model
can you they have done quite a bit
into a smaller neural network so you
start and you have this called teacher
and student you take the fitted model
and generate new data and you fit a
simpler form
people have also done it for editing
models which start from deep learning
and you end up with decision trees you
end up with editing models so you use
this bigger model
to um
guide you and to smoother than the data
and you can
do interpolation too you don't have to
really
stay with most time you do but you don't
have to
where you have the observations
so we want to do because we in this
physics
domain we want to learn wavelet
transform instead of
doing decision tree or editing models
and the goal is to improve
interval ability compression and also
efficiency
so here's one slide
tutorial on wavelets time series just
tile the time and
frequency domain through um
just bars you don't worry about
frequency you just look at every time
point
and the frequency domain create
transform you look at only frequency
domain you ignore the time
and wavelets
you tile
the time and frequency domain in among
strategic matter so you cover both by
also being local
you have much less
in the high frequency you have much much
bigger like
gap so you don't pay as much attention
to high frequencies
but you have this interaction time and
domain time and frequency
so on the left is the govern wavelet
filters
and if you look at the first layer
alexnet
you also miss colored
so if you try to filter out the color
you will see global like things also
come up
so kabob wavelet is kind of
mathematicization of this observed
wavelets like things from supervised
learning you can also get things just
take patches and do unsupervised
learning and there's also neuroscience
work in physiology to show that viva
neurons in the primary cortex also care
about orientation location and frequency
so you also have neuroscience evidence
this might be real
so what we want to do is we have already
pre-trained dna from resnet which works
pretty well for the fundamental
parameter omega m of cosmology
and we want to find
adaptive wavelets
mother wavelet that
will really make things interpretable
to end that design this loss function
with three terms one is reconstruction
loss
to use the wavelet transform if you use
orthogonal variable is invertible the
phi
and then you put it in
in the
transform domain
and
then you put into the prediction rest
net
and you want to make sure the x
head are close
so more or less the file is invertible
and then we also design a wavelet loss
to
make sure that the transform have a high
pass and low pass filter
and we want to make sure they kind of
like wavelets
and then we have a third
interpretation loss so this is taking
the um
[Music]
rest that fitted value and we didn't do
our cd we actually did the gradient
and just it's easier to calculate potash
as a one norm of the gradient one sparse
to be the interpretation still have
three um terms so let me unpack a bit
the second boss
you look at any wavelengths book
all these high and low pass filters have
to satisfy these equations
to
to be uh you start with a mother wavelet
and you expand it to this
fan filters bank filters and
they have to have this equation
satisfied
we didn't really deal with three points
7.31 that's hard to bring into
machine learning algorithms but the
other equation you just turn them into
constraints
so that's part of the uh
wavelength loss
and
you have more constraints we just bring
in
that's for the low pass filter
and both necessary sufficient conditions
we brought it in as equation constraints
and there are also sufficient necessary
conditions for high pass filters
and we penalize as well
yes sufficient conditions for
for what
this addition for the um
high pass and low pass filter so you
start with um
of a mother wavelet and then you can
make up this high pass and low pass
filters
you have
translation and scaling just
automatically made in the wavelet kind
of
enterprise you have a certain way moving
it around and shrink it
and that gives you the high pass and low
faster so for any modern wave that you
can design the high pass low has passed
in a very systematic way
i thought high pass is just the one
which passes three twenty there is some
kind of mathematical definition yeah you
can just um
that's the the d right that's the low um
that's the high pass the g y so you have
the mother wavelet
is called the scaling function
and you have a conjugate mirror filter h
that's the low pass and then you
have all this in the fourier transform
you can just write them down
so giving a mother wavelet what they
call the skating function can just write
this everything down
and this is a condition on these high
pass and low fast pupils
we just turned off this so we explicitly
looking for the g and h's
and we turn this all into
constraints so the equations become
constraints that's what you see how
people use for solving pds with deep
learning
and we do fix the number scale in the
old application we only did five so that
you make a choice so it's not exactly
inverse transform
and this already said you just put these
two uh transformed together and you take
the partial derivative that's our um
kind of interpretation
loss function we took our one
norm of that
and if you simulate using our approach
so you have a synthetic input
and
we took a fully connected net and you
can distill
this uh wavelet so you start with
wavelets add some noise
and then you go through and you feel the
deep learning
and
you um
get the distilled wavelength more or
less equal to the ground truthfully so
this is a proof of concept
and we did a little stability in the
sense that we have
perturbed
the input
so you can see that
if you have sim 5 that's a very well
known wavelet
then
the awd get more or less
and if you add noise you still recover
the uh
kind of uh wgs5 and this is kaufman too
so this is just the one dimensional case
and this is to show again how
initialization my qin think there's you
know there's change
but
you still um more or less get the
weapons back
so back to the cosmology problem
we already designed a francois red
design resnet
and we now have this distilled with it
it turns out that the cosmologists
already use fixed wavelets to
estimate omega m through something
called the peak counting
algorithm
so what we did is that we learned the
distill wavelets
and we plug into the peak counting
method already in the literature
and that's the result
so the prediction area the lower the
better exactly 10 to the minus -4
it's pretty
very high precision
and
the peak height it means
you just use the peak height
and just counting
without doing any wavelengths you get
1.6
if you use laplace kind of wavelet you
get 1.3
you use another wavelet you do 1.2 you
do wg5 don't do as well and rest that
that's much better than all of
that and if you use awli
you get another 10 improvement
and if you don't use the interpretation
loss saying that how
would you get if you just do wavelets
without doing the deep learning part
and you don't do as well so this really
shows that deep learning really helps
um
in terms of hb omega m
beyond
just getting adaptive wavelets
so the peak counting algorithm
is in the literature you just spin into
histograms and then you know the
simulation so you find kind of
like a weighted
quadratic distance and you find the
right one so that's just plugging in
what people doing already with six
vivids
so you look at
what we do here uh the wavelets for the
cosmology
is that there's some trade-off right you
have attribution penalty that's the
interpretation penalty and you also have
a
sparsity penalty
and we use cross-validation to find
the the
this is kind of symmetric a little bit
so this is a measure we designed for um
cosmology
and then we're also working with cell
biologists on a different problem which
is
how do we
observe this process
it's quite amazing that this is a
process how the cells this is now cell
biology
how the cells gets
the food that's one way into the cell so
this horizontal line is the cell
membranes
and first the cell lined up
car goes outside the cell
and then
it created a little
pocket
and then there's scissors
protecting to cut it in and then you
unpack
so this is the process one way
that the cell gets its food into a cell
not through a channel i didn't know
about this until i got this project that
i thought was just old channel but
actually it's really cut it in and
embrace it and then you get the food in
it's a very central process for cell
life
called the classroom mediated
endocytosis
cme
so to understand this process you need
to know all the different biomolecules
how do they interact
and one problem they called molecule
partners it's like which molecules work
with what it's a very challenging
problem and
central
so the classroom
can be observed this is a video
try to follow
where they are
but not every time you see clustering
the
cargo gets successfully put into the
cell so you want to know why is success
so there's another
biomolecule it's more expensive to
follow the green dots
if you see that you know
the the the process is completed not
about it
so the question posed to us was how can
you predict for something easy to
measure to something harder to measure
so we actually have to process a video
into a time series
um
and then we use lhtm
and now we distribute into a wavelet we
end up with 30 coefficients
to do the prediction
uh directly using deep learning on video
actually didn't work very well
we need to really understand the video
process and all the gaussian blurring
all of us turn into time series so
directly working on we do didn't really
work
as we know we do can be challenging for
deep learning
so basic borrowed idea of awp from
cosmology
to this problem
and for here is r square it's um you
want to be high it's like a proportion
like a variance explained
again if you use wavelets directly on
the time series data you get 0.2
lstm get better is that 0.23
awd give you 0.26
so it's about 10 to 15
percent increase in performance and if
you don't use the interpretation loss
again you don't do as well as using the
interpreter saying that lstm does work
or help
uh in this case as well so this is kind
of the generalization you already
develop adaptive wavelets but this is
just used for another problem
and you can also see these
this is you can see the wavelet find is
a symmetric
it's not symmetric as the last one
because
here we already figured out by looking
at all the curves it's really when the
pre
the predictor really peak
and fall that's a good indication the
the process will be completed
any questions
so now we transition to unsupervised
extreme learning right we use gabor
because science or acid is local for
your transform and this is the lab for
your transform
and however the wavelets can also be
kind of derived through
image patches from alexnet
and
dictionary learning is actually a simple
effective measure in representation
learning
but you don't always get vivids
so that's
why digital learning is very interesting
otherwise we all just use wavelets
so this is an older project we try to
figure out how a drosophila fruit fly
in the beginning of the embryo the
different parts as colored by colors
turn into different organs in the adult
root fly so this is developed biology
where you want to figure out the
pre-organ regions and how they turn into
the dial regions and when you have the
data so this is a collaboration with
irvine freeze and sue seneca and anded
experiments and led by my former
students the chi wu and the postdoc
joseph was also engaged
this is a older paper
there's a lot of biological images now i
said there's a lot of science images
people can now really figure out how
genes interact where and when
and
we're looking at the whole self-love
life cycle
we're looking at like two to three hours
so at this you don't see the shape of
the organ so what you see is this
particular gene called aay
where it's expressed
so this is a divine biology where
the different genes you can think of
it's already you have a house you have
already an embryo
and they figured out
where the different organs would be
built
so you can think of as
the different workers work together to
build different rooms in this house
and the different genes depends on where
they are they work with different teams
they don't always work together just
like a painter will be everywhere so a
lot of genes will call you cartagenes we
don't really use it because it's
everywhere
but other genes are more specific in
different locations and we're interested
in gene networks local gene networks
so people already figured out at this
stage there's something called the fade
map
we use ablation they cut different
things out and see which part disappears
so can we reconstruct as a
proof of concept that fade map
to know what they're going to become and
the different colors means
the magenta is a new nerve system so you
know where would the neurosurgeon
develop in the beginning of the embryo
and this is you should show that our
gene expression data is high throughput
has already some information you can see
the two stripes it's a little
can put them together they kind of
inhibit each other so we want to use
modern data to discover
this feedback
and there's a very famous gap gene
network a nobel prize
that we want to reconstruct as kind of a
validation
so that's a fruit fly embryo that's
human embryo
so this is very important network for
called segmentation it's basically how
our
spines develop
and these genes on the circles
the giant here interact with these three
genes
and this here
only integrates true this is all german
name that means if you knock out this
gene the embryo becomes giant
and this is tailless if you knock out
this gene
it's on the tail
the embryo doesn't the fly won't have
tails
so
we use this as a proof of concept so
it's huge amounts of work so this is
another set of scientific images
we have to put them on the same
ellipse so that you can do machine
learning
it was huge amount of work
to get here and we use eric syncs groups
software this is the open us
data set
and default and we also downsampled
because otherwise things won't match so
huge amounts of pre-processing
and i was working on neuroscience at the
time with julia maria iwa bantamini and
and we want the fade map and that's like
a decomposition so let's try dictionary
learning
we end up using non-linear measure
factorization but we started with
extreme learning it's kind of boring
from neuroscience yes
so these are different genes
each image is a different gene
and this says that this change spreads a
lot here and here
and this string is everywhere
yes actual embryo after we warped it
into this shape
it's not all very nice actually
the embryo 3d right it has to be the
right
facing to the microscope
otherwise it's not right so there's a
lot of manual annotation
you have to see the little guy had to
lie in the right way when the photo was
shot
and then we
put them into this is everything group's
software
put them and then make them into like
comparable uh
images because they have different sizes
thank you for the question so this is a
different genes so
you hope
for the co-occurrence you figure out the
different uh sides of
like different pre-organs
so we use dictionary learning so we
turned each
gene expression just into a vector
without coding the neighborhood
information just you of course you need
to do a fixed way make into a long
vector
you do dictionary learning or do uh
matrix factorization
you end up with this
we call principal patterns they are just
the items
and the very nice thing is that
even we didn't put any spatial
constraints the principle patterns
came up to be continuous in space
these are the preorder regions these are
the basic
units like the room
flow plan that different genes work
together
and the biologists recognize that
they're very meaningful
and
questions how many we should choose
so we use this stability principle
um
you take
random
so we have random starting points
of
to subsample the data so for fixed k say
20
and you do many runs we have many
different starting points and
the non-electromagnetization
condition one on the other is convex
otherwise is non-complex and use
correlation to match them
and you
look at the distance similarities
right so you end up with two dictionary
sets of we call principal patterns you
find the best match from one side to the
other
and you minus that if it's one you get
zero so that perfect match
and this this similarity can be used
over many runs
as an index to select number of
components
so there's a clear minimum at 21 and 22
is pretty close so we did take a look at
22. 22 is that splitting while the
region into two and the biologists said
you know it's too small
so we stayed with 21.
so this is using stability to
select the number of principal patterns
or the number of components
uh here they are
i was really amazed that it's almost
like you have
vertical horizontal and anterior and
posterior
very much organized and aligned
and the biology is recognized
they are meaningful
but we didn't stop they just said you
said so we really tried to figure out
for different regions which genes
expressed now we have this concept of
regions like rooms
and we look at which genes are
overexpressed
whether it match with what people know
already and we also do the prediction
we can reconstruct the gap network we
miss one link
and then we end up doing some theory
so that's where we started doing theory
and we also did knock out experiments so
the nokia experiments
i would say that we have 40 of them we
still couldn't analyze them because we
had a problem finding a phenotype we
find a very important gene was diesel
but still couldn't come up with the
story-wise diesel so you now have this
gene which has very little information
now
the embryo dies at 16th hour so it's
very important
but our local gene network was not right
using correlation
so if you lay out all these 21 principle
patterns on top of the feed map now you
have conjectured
functionality for these regions like the
the one
in there is magenta because fo this is
all schematic
that
pp5 probably is about
brain development
and
you have hingai that's become the
stomach and you have
uh much
mesoderm that's about the skin so all of
that
we can conjecture the functionality i'm
going to see which genes are
expressed small here
and then we
can actually um
compare with the literature
so
we were able to reconstruct this famous
gap g network except for that one link
we
there there is a little bit of evidence
but we
couldn't
uh really our cutoff which is before we
check this
didn't meet that cutoff
so this is kind of a validation that
so we really need to trust these
regions we found
and i was very interested in doing some
theory on dictionary learning to see
when we actually can trust what are the
conditions
that will make the dictionary learning
work we couldn't underline that
non-inclination factorization so we went
for the easy mathematical tractable
bit
there is
this work uh
and we're looking at actually under
um
not over complete but under complete
case and you can filter it in to make it
a square case
so si chi wu was the lead on the science
project he's also mathematically able
and he really
did the old heavy lifting on the proofs
that
reformulate the problem because the
square case through the matrix inversion
into our y minimization problem instead
of
um
you have two parameters
the coefficients and d you want to find
but because the square case we can turn
the alpha problem into a d problem so we
only have one
unknown which is a reference we call
referential
defined
so the literature have this gaussian a
bernoulli gaussian model
this is a noiseless case
we assume that
people assume that
you have
distribution d0
and alpha one
you have a flip a bernoulli flip
and then you have a magnitude
oh a continuous case which is gaussian
so that's called the bernoulli gaussian
model
with probably dp which controls sparsity
you have keep them or don't keep them
you also have a fixed case when you
don't put pr um distribution rf but
result pretty similar so i won't present
here
so p is the sparsity
if you look at the uh now we have only
one
unknown which is d
if you can understand the population
version the sample between the sample
and the population can be controlled by
the usual um
complex ethereal units of convergence so
we concentrate on the population
loss function
the first question is when the
dictionary will be identifiable
because now the convex problem
and you can see that
the minimum will be sine and permutation
in variance because there's no reason
why
a particular column is one or two right
so
it's permutation and sine environment we
can change the sign of the column of d
and also change the sign of alpha you
get the same
observed data back
the first question is when the reference
distribution you have a generated model
would be a local minimum of the
population
loss function
so here are the prior results
that
um
the 20
10 paper is a complete case
and give a sufficient condition with
comparison special case for local uh
identifiability
and
we will also move on to over complete
case we stayed with the complete case
and there was some work on
identifiability for non-actual material
factorization
and there are many other works
which listed here
so local identifiability
if a dictionary is a local minimum it's
a sign and
signed permutation matrix it's also a
local minimum because the whole problem
is invariant
the local identifiability people usually
define through local through global oh
the global identifiability usually
defines through global minimum but we're
going to introduce another concept
to identify the reference distribution
which is doesn't depend on global
minimum
so we have two papers
and the first one was cg as i mentioned
we were able to give
basically a necessary sufficient
condition which is the equal sign we
don't know for local identity value for
the bernoulli gaussian model or the
k-sparse model
and for the newer work
we're able to remove
the gaussian assumption
so remember there's a bernoulli you toss
you remove and we only need a continuous
density for the the size
the reason we need that is because
we moved from diction learning to
non-negative expression that everything
is positive for the coefficients so we
want to see whether
that will make things easier for
ourselves because empirically we like
that better we start with dictionary
learning we end up imposing a positivity
so this new work actually mathematically
is a different approach it's really huge
work
allows us to do the positive which the
early work couldn't
and then we went for
some
version global identifiability doesn't
depends on global minimum you can
construct a case in this case
that counter example
the reference distribution is now global
minimum but it has a characterizing
property called the sharper local
minimum
so to do um
oh to really
write out our identifiability
conditions we define semi norm
based on the random coefficients
so for any matrix a
the three bar seminar is defined through
this formula rf is a random variable
remember the
coefficients and it can be zero set by
with but only probability p
and
it's really
can be written
in two terms
so we can
have this almost necessary and
sufficient conditional local
identifiable i would call bernoulli type
when you remove the gaussian assumption
the m is the correlation between the
columns of your dictionary
your reference issue
and then
this matrix you care about you're going
to go through this alpha number
is that
it concerns all the coefficients and the
sign
so this is really about the kind of
correlation between
the different
components of alpha if it's independent
then if this means zero this term
disappears this is really related to
coherence or incoherence
and this one
it's kind of a scaling factor on top of
the coherence
so if this quantity in the journal is
less than one
then the reference distribution is a
local minimum of the population
if it's larger than one
it's not a local minimum we don't know
why it's equal
that's the almost natural sense
efficient
it's kind of reminiscent with the real
representable condition for the surah
you have the mix of the coefficients
with signs it's not the same
i have some coherence in there
but it's a different form
it's easier to interpret it's
in this form
it's um
this matrix is easier to interfere the
the norm i don't think i have a good
explanation in the
in the particular case you can see it
but otherwise it's very convoluted
but the matrix you can see this is about
coherence scale by the size of the
coefficient
and this is about the correlation
between the different components of the
coefficients
here you don't even under the
independent assumption
then if this is mean zero then you have
mean zero otherwise they all kind of
interact
somehow two correlation term one is
about dictionary y is about the
coefficient
but the proof
is actually like with matrix reality you
can get something like a tailor
expansion for the population
loss
not exactly
but you can kind of think that way and
that's how you have kind of tell
expansion type of thinking going
and
get the results
so let's look at the simple case then
you can see something so
if you have a reference distribution
that the columns has a constant
correlation mu
then
if you have a sparse gaussian
with velocity s
k times p because the result were
equivalent
then you have the nice tree though right
when the sparsity is high you need the
coherence to be low
if you have very
low sparsity
oh like you have very few coefficients
non-zero then you can tolerate them all
uh
dependence so that's that's kind of the
bound it's um
not one over s but
like one over squared of s
but the interesting bit
is if you have an
non-negative gaussian because remember
we want to go to non-negativity
because we end up using non-information
factorization and you have kind of a
weird
thing going on here is that
when you have
high sp like very dense
a new is high
it kind of
helps
instead of hurts that's the opposite
what i would think
and one possible interpretation we came
up with is that
when you have
mu very high in this case because
positivity you have much smaller search
space somehow and then make things
easier for yourself
so the positivity has a very funny
interaction with the sparsity and
incoherence that i would have imagined
unless you have all these derivations i
have the results out
and this is again for that simple like a
coherence symmetrical coherence matrix
we basically got the
yellow
curve
and
this is the bounce from previous uh
people have got upper bound i got lower
bound and we basically characterize the
whole boundary
um for when things work one thing
doesn't work just on the previous slide
so to derive this condition
calculating the semi norm yeah so you
can like anxiety
so that the 2d example is even easier
right so the 2d example
you can just get exactly the
relationship right for gaussian without
the negative and the positivity
constraint you need the coherence to be
less than one minus p
but if you have
non-negative
you don't need any conditional sparsity
any coherence would be fine
and same example
you can just plug in and you can plot
and see that the condition really tells
you
when
you will get um
the reference distribution will be the
population a minimum
so for global identifiability people
just define through global minimum
and there are various conditions about
you have constraints and the sparsity
and
the aurora papers start with some
clustering and then
that
they do do negative
coefficients
and then here's a counter example
that
for this example you can see that the
global minimum
is not the reference distribution is not
the generating reference distribution is
not the global minimum
so the z has a mixture of gaussian
that's the the non-zero part and then
you multiply by a bernoulli which is kc
with probability p
v non-zero
because you're projecting
for every component you end up having
the alpha has
eight arms not four
because you set something here one being
zero get projected there and get pretty
bad so you end up with this eight kind
of arm
a distribution for alpha
and
you can show that
the reference distribution i generated
is actually
not
a global minimum
and the global minimum
is
achieved
by
something related to the grain
so this is the case that if you want to
do this problem you cannot stay with
global minimum
we end up borrowing this old concept
well owned at least from the 70 called
the sharp global minimum
from optimization
defined in that way so you kind of
lower bonding with the forbidden is now
just a little bit padding
and
not the square
that is called the sharp local minimum
and then we can show that when this
condition holds let's receive a local
minimum
it's a unique sharp local minimum so you
don't look at it's a global property
because no other dictionary will satisfy
that
and this is uniquely defined as
reference
dictionary it's the only oneness one
that holds satisfy the local shop local
minimum
but you cannot stay with the uh
global minimum
here's a very quick
idea on the proof
um
since we can
do that the inverse
and you basically show that this vector
is exactly k minus one
in the subspace of k minus one and uh
from this you can kind of prove that
other dictionaries
don't satisfy that and therefore they
cannot be sharp global minimum
and
how do you check the sharper global we
know we design a kind of stability type
of
numerical algorithm
and it's kind of reminiscent to the
stability for selecting the number of
components as it is not exactly the same
but it's like if things perturb things
doesn't change much then you know it's a
sharp global minimum
and more recently i've been using this
dictionary learning for another genomics
data from the other institute for brain
science to collaborate with my
pharmaceutical and ucsf and people at
and also hugh wong who is on the
lead also on the theory
project and bunch of people from atlanta
institute this is a 3d expression
so a dial mouse brain
and
people also hand annotated
the different brain regions but this
will make it data driven
so what they like
about
what we came up with there's some parts
they already know
other parts we have more refined regions
than they knew
smaller
the big one they kind of knew so that's
why
and we end up with 18 principal patterns
here instead of so there was a local
minimum at 13.
and through discussions we still took
the global number 18 because they have
more regions than what people knew
already
to summarize
i was really advocating for more people
get interested in scientific machine
learning
and interpretation is hugely important
for scientific
machine learning
and we use science to derive
um
the adaptive wavelet which worked for
cosmology that was a motivating case and
then we just borrowed it for another
problem and that worked really well
and then dictionary learning
we have been very um successful using it
oh it's variant non-eximation
factorization they're not the same as
you know the positivity
for two biological problems and both
gene expression one neuroscience finding
different biology and
we're able to do some theory kind of
supporting the use of non-negativity
because with that constraint you have
relaxed smaller like conditions
so the current directions right so we
went for wavelets for cosmology
without
doing diction learning
because we like the wavelengths people
use biblics that make sense there and we
use it
but if you use dictionary learning on
this cosmology images if you take a
small 12 by 12 patches
you don't get any pattern out
if you take the whole image use
independent component analysis
you can at least get something out
the definition is very strong inductive
biases depends on the formulation
dependent algorithm
and we need more investigation just
because these two are separate projects
just this week i get uh we should help
me to get some of this the question is
do we find new patterns
are they meaningful are we adding
anything to the
wavelets that people already do
and for the both strategical friend
writers a lot of we have
actually in that paper uh interactive
but not really practical it's like full
we specify models then just doesn't work
and there are many good works
on local convergence you could have one
from
peter
and our rx group and
but local convergence and there's a very
interesting paper from 2010
from
banjos group
if you
so auto encode is kind of another
version of dictionary multi-layers
and you add noise to it if you don't
know how to auto-encode it wouldn't give
you a wavelength but if you add noise to
it it gives you a auto encoder
can we show some local convergence of
this uh very interesting algorithm so
that's where we are
and to leave you like
i started with imagenet with a lot of
very exciting scientific images that
hopefully will help to further develop
deep learning and science
thank you
maybe one question and then we can uh go
for the
um
yeah so the notion of the
interpretability that you use
with the
way
you know it's part of the pipeline is it
sort of sparsity
yeah
adaptive movement yeah yeah
so um
i guess they they could be many other
yeah
yeah
so for example we quite like our cd but
it's harder to program and because you
do derivative python to just make the
programming very easy
i guess one advantage there is you have
this very non-interpretable theme yeah
but it's surrounded by something that
you know is in some sense simple
yeah i think there's something
fundamental i think beyblades or free
domain i think
my conjecture is that there's certain
cluster problems that relate to physical
science just one layer wavelength kind
of enough
for those problems
but somehow
the difference still helped
which i don't quite understand
somehow wanting to a space that if you
just directly to
adapt to make this without the
interpretation part you get worse
results
i don't quite fully understand but
somehow that seems to be there's a value
to going to deep learning
and there will be also some cases where
wavelets so when you try to add layers
or maybe it doesn't work because i think
after the division
at least for vision after the first
layer
the other layer you need other kind of
filters
oh wait
in hindsight i was pretty obvious but we
did try
so
yeah it's l1
we love to program for cd by just like
the programming just too much
at least we
we don't have a package to use right
everything we coded up
and taking
yeah so that's why we went for l1
we thought that we'll get worse
prediction performance
we're happy just to go for something
more concise
like for the
we end up with like just 30 like
coefficients or something right which
you know less than a huge number
relatively
but the prediction also got better
that was a nice price
there's a lot of images i think out
there now i think
and the technology imaging just really
advancing
thank you